zugeschaltet ist und gustav gräßel er
ist senior policy fellow am european
council on foreign relations in berlin
schön dass sie dabei sind adresse
bleiben wir mal gerade bei der eben am
ende gesehen stadt sowie ansgar schreibt
heute der gouverneur der region auf
telegramm wieder einmal zählen die
russen absichtlich auf orte an denen
sich zivilisten aufhalten das ist
schlicht und ergreifend terrorismus wie
bewerten sie die lage dort im moment
die lage ist enorm angespannt
amateurs wurden ja seit 2014 militärisch
ausgebaut es gibt starke stellung
systeme die kann man gut verteidigen
aber natürlich sind es auch zwei größere
städte die jetzt acht jahren relativ
frieden leben und die jetzt unter
beschuss kommen man muss auch dazu sagen
dass die russische artillerie und die
russischen raketen nicht sehr präzise
sind dh man kann nicht unterscheiden
zwischen militärischen zielen sondern
man schießt einfach hinein in die städte
die man sozusagen erobern will es bleibt
ja von denen dann auch nach der
eroberung recht wenig übrig und beide
städte sind auch wichtige
eisenbahnknoten punkte für die ukraine
also hier werden ja auch reserven
ausgeladen hier kommt ein neuer
nachschub an in dem sinn muss damit
ausgegangen werden dass ich das bonbon
sowohl durch artillerie als auch durch
die russische luftwaffe noch in den
nächsten wochen stark verstärken wird
nun werfen wir mal ganz kurz hier einen
blick auf meinem notebook und sehen
einen tweet von boris johnson dem
britischen premierminister der heute
getwittert hat er hat mit präsidentin
lenski darüber gesprochen was bei g 7
und nato letzte woche beschrieben
worüber gesprochen wurde und er schreibt
aber auch ich glaube dass das
ukrainische militär die jetzt von putins
kräften besetzten gebiete wieder
zurückerobern kann wie positiv sehen sie
das er hat in seinem tweet ja auch unten
das entscheidende angeführt am morgen
meditiert wahlkampf führen also mehr
militärhilfe wird bald kommen und das
ist das was
das entscheiden ist die ukraine hat
genügend soldatinnen und soldaten die
kämpfen etwa 700.000 mann unter waffen
es gab mobil machen es gibt jede menge
freiwillige das problem ist ihr fehlt
die feuerkraft ja viel die die
mechanisierte beweglichkeit die panzer
die schützen waren seit die artillerie
um in einem offenem gelände den russen
entgegen stehen zu können im infanterie
geländer in stetten da können sie zu
verteidigen aber man braucht zum
verteidigen eben auch gepanzerte
mechanisierte einheiten und das ist das
entscheidende
der zeit wo es bei der ukraine hat man
hat zu wenig und die kriegsverluste bis
jetzt werde über vier monate im krieg
die waren ja auch auf ukrainischer seite
erheblich und man muss sich ausgleichen
und das schwächt die ukrainische
offensivkraft sollten sich diese
waffenlieferungen beschleunigen dann hat
der ukraine durchaus chance hier gebiete
wieder zurückgerufen
tja wir müssen den nachschub der
besatzer brechen wir müssen dem druck
standhalten sagt der präsident gustav
kressl der militärexperte ist bei uns
und ich möchte direkt in dieses thema
waffen jetzt einsteigen weil es so viele
interessiert noch mal die frage direkt
vom nutzer nutzer mit 3m mich würde
interessieren inwiefern die
panzerhaubitze 2000 hilft wie groß ist
der vorteil besserer waffensysteme
wirklich ist hier die frage
die panzerhaubitze 2000 ist ist schon
eines der besten wertung systeme dass
die ukraine jetzt hat ihn bekommen hat
also ich von den ukrainern nur positives
lob dafür gehört angeblich soll eine
panzerhaubitze
2000 ungefähr so effektiv sein wie die
drei
amerikanischen triple seven ist
natürlich ein gezogenes geschützt nicht
so mobil wie ein panzer offiziell das
problem natürlich bei der panzerhaubitze
2000 ist dass es nur wenige davon gibt
also sie werden dort vor allen dingen
eingesetzt wo starke russische
artillerie gibt weil sie sehr
weitreichend ist weil man die russische
artillerie die weit hinter der front
steht damit noch bekämpfen kann aber es
ist wie immer nur ein punktueller
einsatz weil wie gesagt die anzahl
natürlich auf 1200 kilometer langen
front auch leicht unter geht aber
qualitativ ist es ein sehr gutes gerät
eine frage von caterpillar auch ich
glaube über youtube das sind zwei fragen
eine greife ich jetzt mal raus bekommt
die ukraine auch weiter setzt
es gibt gespräche mit der slowakei dass
die 12 29 aus der slowakei bekommen
könnte dass diese gespräche sind relativ
weit die könnte sie bekommen sonst gibt
es keine zusagen und man hat dass er zum
beispiel ausgeschlossen dass frankreich
welche liefern wird gibt es da eher
zurückhaltung das problem natürlich auch
dass die ukraine hat das muss dann mit
raketen mitmachen körpern die
ukrainischen luftwaffenbasen schon
angegriffen hat beziehungsweise ständig
angreift die ukraine muss ihre
kampfflugzeuge die immer noch im einsatz
sind ja verteilen auf verschiedene
kleine flughäfen landepisten zum teil
auf bundesstraßen und autobahnen stücke
die gerade sind gerade genug dass man
mit dem kampfflugzeug startet und landet
ist ein zäher dezentralisierter einsatz
aber es gibt noch die ukrainische
luftwaffen fliegt und sie fliegt auch
relativ viel denn selbst mit großen
weiträumigen luft apple systemen wie
etwa als 300 kann man ja in der größe
des landes nur einen geringen teil
abdecken und um über allein ein gewisses
risiko für respekt vor allen dingen für
russische bomber darzustellen nicht in
den ukrainischen luftraum vorzudringen
unterhält man noch diese direkt einsätze
zweiter teil der frage von caterpillar
hat gräßel ist es möglich dass die
ukraine die gelieferten waffen
zurückhaltend für eine gegenoffensive
da ist ja gerade auch immer wieder im
süden des landes die rede bei der
ukrainischen regierung von einer
offensive die da geplant ist für wie
aussichtsreich und realistisch halten
sie das und natürlich auch die frage ist
es möglich dass die ukraine dafür waffen
bewusst zurückhält
davon weiß ich nichts so sie die waffen
es ist auch diese diese offensive
eigentlich schon im gang seit mehreren
wochen das problem ist es fehlt wie
gesagt der ukraine an gepanzerten
fahrzeugen es fehlt die feuerkraft also
dort wo die lücken in der in den
ukrainisch den russischen stellungen
entdeckt dass sie durchkommt weiter die
ukrainischen kräfte sind zum teil ganz
gut geführt also praktisch
viel flexibler geführt als die als die
russischen streifte das machen sie das
problem ist dann wenn sich auf starken
befestigten russischen widerstand stoßen
dann ist das feuerkraft manko ebenda
dann kommen sie ein problem das auch
stock dieser angriff jetzt auch
zurückbehalten tun sie im grunde nicht
es gibt natürlich was das das einführen
neuer waffensysteme angeht immer so eine
sozusagen eine phasenweise einsatz also
gerade wenn sie mehrere gerät bekommen
damit sie erst mal im ausland trainiert
dann an wenigen besatzungen wie dieses
gerät umzugehen ist und diese bilden
dann in der ukraine weiter ukrainische
besatzungen in größerer anzahl an diesem
gerät aus und dann kommt das erst in
größerer stückzahl zum einsatz
dieser phasenweise einsatz habe er mit
dem ausbildungs und dem dem aufbau
logistische infrastruktur zu tun als
jetzt mit einem zurückhaltend für eine
gegenoffensive vielleicht kann man für
die nächste frage noch mal die karte
einblenden die wir eben gesehen haben
die zeit nämlich nicht nur den osten
land des landes sondern auch den süden
über den sie auch gerade gesprochen
haben und dazu gibt es eine frage von
stereo tp 95 wie hoch wird die chance
eingeschätzt dass die russischen truppen
nach einnahme des dollars weiter nach
transnistrien marschieren und die
ukraine vom schwarzen meer abschneiden
hier sehen wir es noch mal versonnen im
osten nikolov und odessa dann im westen
ja ja das ist eine der die ermöglichen
angriffs richtungen das uns zurzeit in
die russischen kräfte zu schwach um hier
weiter angreifen zu können aber wenn sie
den daumen fast vollständig erobert
hätten dann mögen dort natürlich kräfte
frei und
man kann sie dann entweder um karten
neues gefecht schmeißen um sozusagen das
noch mal zu probieren oder man kann sie
richtung süden werfen richtung wo
deshalb fasst deshalb für für
wahrscheinlicher allerdings hier ist ja
auch nicolai fein gezeichnet das ist der
untere buch das ist ein sehr großer
fluss sehr breiter fluss der schwer zu
überwinden ist und wo es nur alle 100
kilometer eine eisenbahn oder
straßenbrücke darüber gibt das heißt
hier hätte er auch die ukraine noch mal
eine eine widerstandslinie die man gut
besetzen kann brücken sprengen kann muss
es noch wirklich schwer machen kann über
diesen fluss zu kommen und könnte das
auch länger verteidigen also dass das
muss auch hier gesagt sein das ist nicht
so einfach wie es oft auf der karte
ausschaut eine frage von frank ebeling
ebenso über youtube frage an den
experten wäre es aus sicht der
ukrainischen streitkräfte nicht schlau
die russische armee durch entsprechende
aufstellung in die breite front zu
zwingen
dass also die erste phase des krieges da
haben die ukraine ihre flexibilität
jetzt
unter sozusagen besser ausnutzen können
weil die russen tief schmalen tief
gestoßen sind man hat sehr schnell die
russen versucht schnell in die tiefe zu
gehen ortschaften die sie nicht
einnehmen konnten einfach umgehen um
einfach schnell rasch in die ukrainische
tiefe und fiel geländegewinne zu machen
das problem das sie dann hatten des
ersten die die eigene lage wirklich zu
erfassen wo sind eigene truppen wo ist
da gegner dass sie dann nachschub
probleme bekommen haben weil die eigenen
kräfte überdehnt waren das die
koordinationsprobleme vor allen dingen
mit afrika wer mit der elektronischen
kampfführung bekommen haben und das
machen sie es nicht mehr jetzt greifen
sie ebenso zu sagen er auf breiter front
an ihr langsam mit wenig tiefe dann
können sie ihre angriffe besser
koordinieren dann können sie die
teilstreitkräfte besser koordinieren
dann können sie unterschiedliche
elektronische störungen cetera zeitmäßig
besser koordinieren die luft an
beschläge besser koordinieren
damit machen sie natürlich keine
spektakulären siege aber so langsam
schlingt sich die feuerwalze vorwärts
und das ist für die ukraine
problematischer als diese diese schmalen
tiefen stöße weil die ukraine wie schon
vorher gesagt habe besser geführt sind
also flexiblere strukturen haben auf
bessere offizieren die können wenn sie
offene flanken haben diese nutzen die
können sie wenn sie einen rückraum haben
dann dann stoßen sie da rein schauen
dass sie die russen ausrichtungen
angreifend aus denen dass die russen
nicht vermutet und erwartet haben das
problem ist wenn so eine breite
feuerwalze kommt die hand nehmen eine
offene flanke die kann ich im grunde
auch nicht überraschend weil die geht
sozusagen stur nach nachschuss plan
voran zuschießt eine linie dazu schießt
ihr die nächste linie dann bleiben wir
taktisch wenig möglichkeiten übrig die
auszutricksen
ich zitiere den einen sehr engen berater
des ukrainischen präsidenten von heute
michael opodo jack der hat in einem
interview gesagt wir minimieren unsere
verluste und ein vorübergehender rückzug
aus der region luhansk und lohans
bedeutet nicht den verlust des dollars
sondern bedeutet dass wir ihn auf
korrekte weise zurückerhalten werden wie
ist das denn einzuordnen
der zweite teil der aussage auf korrekte
weise zurückgehalten das ist natürlich
jetzt sehr vage und
dass das ist noch relativ ferne
zukunftsmusik dass man die eigenen
verluste minimiert dass man die eigenen
verluste versucht hintanzuhalten die man
sich auslöschen zurückgezogen hat das
stimmt dass es gab dieses kettemann
länger halten können das problem war im
süden der stadt im südosten und osten
gab es eine russische einbruch und dort
haben die russen wichtige gelände
anhöhen ihm dem süden unserem südwesten
der stadt erobert und von dort haben sie
die gesamten nachschub und
verkehrslinien die nachlese ganz klein
gegen einblick nehmen können das heißt
ja martelly auf jeden transporter
anfordern können sie haben genau gewusst
und genau gesehen wo die ukrainer sich
bewegen und das hätte ähnlich wie die
walze wie 2015 ein verhängnisvoller
kessel werden können da haben die
ukraine geschaut dass sie vor allen
dingen in der nacht die russische
nachtsichtgeräte sind nicht besonders
gut ihre truppen daraus bewegen und dass
sie es ernst er aufgeben als da sich ein
herr exponierte position zu bewegen
dann nehmen wir mal eine frage nach den
waffen nach den waffenlieferungen
kevin kosubek über youtube fragt mal
hypothetisch wie groß wäre der vorteil
mit dem leopard 2 wenn die russischen
streitkräfte jetzt schon alte panzer wie
den tee 62 einsetzen müssen
das hängt natürlich mein lieber zwei
auch sehr stark davon ab welche variante
von würde man verwenden also ich nehme
nicht an dass die bundeswehr ihre neuen
leopard 2 627 abgibt sondern dass es
sich um gebrauchte leopard 2 4
handelt die von anderen europäischen
streitkräften schon ausgemustert wurden
und jetzt beim hersteller wieder
gelandet sind dieser panzer hätte vor
allen dingen einen vorteil was die optik
angeht das nachtsichtgerät das wäre welt
gerät ist ein sehr gutes die kanone ist
auch präziser als die russischen die
durchschlagsstelle mit der alten
munition es gibt sehr unterschiedliche
gas drücke maximale gas drückt erlaubt
sind ist jetzt nicht vor enthof auf die
panzerung ist das ehepaar 24 liegt jetzt
hinter modernsten varianten dass die 72
zurück aber er sieht besser an der trift
schneller und er hat einen besseren
feuer leitrechner das heißt er hat einen
feuerkraft vorteil und er ist
überlebensfähiger das heißt selbst wenn
er getroffen wird dann ist die chance
dass das ganze fahrzeug mit mann und
maus abbrennt wie bei bahn sein
sowjetischer bauart nicht so hoch
gegeben weil die munition anders
verstaut wird und das ist auch ein
problem dass beide seiten haben sowohl
die russin als auch die ukraine durch
diese verwundbarkeit der sowjetischen
ganzer die eben bei einem direkt treffer
der durchschlägt und zu magazin kommt
sofort in die luft fliegt und alle drei
besatzungsmitglieder
umbringt dass die erfahrenen tanzer
besatzungen langsam abhanden kommen man
kann ja die 62 über den kann man spotten
was man will das größte problem ist der
wurde milizen aus der generellen er zum
teil in die hand gedrückt die man extra
darauf ausbilden hat müssen weil man
eigentlich keine panzer besatzungen mehr
hat die mit solchen dingen umgehen
können und der nicht artgerecht
eingesetzte panzer selbst wenn er gut
ist ist noch viel schlechteres gerät als
ein ein gut geführter mit erfahrenen
soldaten und panzer in dem sie wäre
natürlich für die ukraine der leopard
aufgrund seiner überlebensfähigkeit ein
ein wichtiges assets weil die eigenen
panzer besatzungen dann eben länger
überleben und ihr wissen auch
weitergeben können und ihr wissen auch
länger ansammeln können das auf der
russischen seite damit sind wir dann
auch bei der frage nach der ausbildung
bisher wurden ja viele westliche
waffensystemen nicht geliefert mit dem
argument dass man dann die ausbildung
neben der ukrainischen soldaten
irgendwie bewerkstelligen muss und dass
das nicht zielführend sei zumindest
nicht im moment wir schauen gerade hier
noch mal auf meinem notebook und gucken
noch einmal auf die liste der
bundesregierung die die ausstellung ja
jetzt veröffentlicht was sie liefern
will an die ukraine was vor allem
interessantes ist der aktuelle stand
nämlich dienstag der 28 juni ist es wird
wöchentlich aktualisiert
keine ahnung ob das im laufe des
heutigen tages noch passiert aber im
moment haben wir den stand von letzter
woche wir sehen hier 22 lkw erste hilfe
kids wir sehen drei mehrfach
raketenwerfer mars und zum beispiel 30
panzer gepa das ist alles bekannt und
wir sehen aber herr dressel dass er
damit schon viele waffensysteme
westlicher bauart geliefert werden das
heißt es spreche ja eigentlich nichts
dagegen zum beispiel
sie haben den leopard gerade
angesprochen zusagen der krieg wird
lange dauern es wird sich lohnen diese
ausbildung zu machen und dann doch mehr
und mehr westliche waffensysteme zu
liefern ja natürlich also die ausbildung
dauert natürlich eine zeit auch die
logistische vorbereitung dauert
natürlich eine zeit aber der krieg
dauert länger also ich hab das
zentrum liberale moderne im märz schrift
verfasst was man der ukraine alles geben
könnte und wie lange das in etwa dauern
würde und wir liegen jetzt im juli schon
in dem zeitraum wo schon viele dinge
auch hätten eingeführt werden können
hätte man sich damals dafür entschieden
desto länger man das aus zögert desto
schneller muss man dann rudeln das
problem ist für viele sowjetische
waffensysteme verfügen wir einfach nicht
über eine einem nachwuchs kette an
munition an ersatzteilen weil mir die
dinge nicht mehr herrscht und dann muss
ersatz geschaffen werden also ihres
teams und klassisches beispiel da da war
deutschland er der erste start gesagt
hat weitreichende system das liefern wir
und das war auch gut und richtig die
ausbildung wird natürlich dauern das
kommt erst im november so jetzt so wie
es aussieht aber die der kritische punkt
ist die sowjetischen flieger systeme
s-300 buch im 1 die raketen für diese
systeme werden ausschließlich in
russland hergestellt und da kriegt man
einfach auf dem schwarzmarkt auch nicht
genügend munition um so einen krieg
länger durchhalten zu können um städte
länger schützen zu können um wichtige
infrastruktur gegen luftangriffe länger
schützen zu können dann müssen
irgendwann raketen her die im westen
gebaut werden das gibt es nur für
westliche systeme jetzt haben die
amerikaner auch ein system angekündigt
und sozusagen so langsam pendelt sich
das 1 das ausbildungs argument das hat
in erster linie gezogen am anfang des
krieges als man noch nicht gewusst hat
wird die ukrainische armee eigentlich
diesen krieg länger durchhalten können
wird die ukraine in drei wochen fallen
oder nicht macht es dann sinn geräte zu
liefern die mehrere monate in der
ausbildung brauchen oder nicht jetzt
wissen wir dass die ukraine überlebt und
das bei der gegenseite derzeitigen
angriffs geschwindigkeit der russischen
armee die die ukraine länger überleben
wird als alle möglichen trainings und
ausbildungs auf wende bedeuten würden
das heißt jetzt sollte man sich
eigentlich an einen tisch setzen unter
den nato alliierten auch schauen wie
kriegen wir denn die kritische masse an
fahrzeugen zustande also wo ist es nicht
so dass sozusagen der eine liefert fünf
panzer und dann nächste liefert drei
panzer b und dann hat die ukraine mit
mit 30 verschiedenen systemen zu kämpfen
sondern wo man ausbildung vereinfachen
wo man logistik vereinfachen kann indem
man sich auf gewisse plattformen einig
und die dann den großen stückzahlen
liefert um eben in einer
materialschlacht diesem abnutzungskrieg
dann auch wirklich einen unterschied zu
machen zwei letzte fragen zum thema
waffen möchte ich gerne noch bündeln
einmal fragt ein user namens partie sind
panzer sehr wichtig für die ukraine oder
müsste man mehr waffen gegen den
luftraum geben und die andere frage
waltraud tee fragt über facebook wie
viel schwerere waffen braucht denn die
ukraine um überhaupt eine chance zur
rückeroberung zu haben mir scheint dass
das was derzeit zugesagt wurde bei
weitem nicht ausreicht
ja also um das zweite sofort zu
beantworten ja das ist also die ukraine
hat zb vor dem krieg einem bestand von
kampfpanzern gehabt
fast 2.000 verschiedene rohr artillerie
systeme und etwa 400 raketen artillerie
systeme jetzt ist natürlich festliche
waffen leistungsfähiger man muss das
nicht eins zu eins ersetzen was jedem
krieg verloren geht aber in einer 1200
kilometer langen front kann man
natürlich den ausfall verschiedene
waffensysteme und die die kriegsverluste
die die manchen klassen bis zu 50% des
vorkriegs bestands jetzt schon ausmachen
nicht einfach doch ganz wenige systeme
ausmachen weil die front einfach solange
es an meinem schiedene richtungen
bedienen kann bedienen muss aus
ukrainischer sicht und das
da gibt es in etwa listen was die
ukraine bräuchte das natürlich bemessen
einer kriegs dauert mindestens bis
nächsten sommer
die die hören sich auf den ersten blick
natürlich for rent an
ist aber ist aber natürlich in einem so
einem krieg wo die zwei größten landes
in europa aufeinander stoßen jetzt gar
nicht so gar nicht so abwegig da redet
man von etwa 500 kampfpanzern und und
etwa 1000 bis 2000 anderen gepanzerten
fahrzeugen und über 1000 artillerie
systeme es gibt ihnen hat opels gesagt
auf die altbestände an solchen geräten
also 109 gibt es in den usa etwa 850 um
ein beispiel zu nehmen dass eine
panzerhaubitze älter ist als die
panzerhaubitze 2000 aber
nichtsdestotrotz 850 stück das ist meine
nummer
113 gab es in der nato im kalten krieg
in rauen mengen und
stehen auch in deutschland noch einige
herum die exportiert werden könnten in
den usa gibt es auch noch größere
bestände der frauen also wir haben das
gerät das klingt alles furchtbar aber
das ist da
bansa was die ukraine braucht die
ukraine braucht alle dieses thema weil
der kampf der verbundenen waffen bedingt
dass man sich gegenseitig unterstützt
die ukraine braucht die kampfpanzer für
die direkte feuerkraft die volle
unterstützung im direkten gefecht
genauso wie sie die artillerie braucht
um gegnerische artillerie auszuschalten
um feindliche infanterie niederzuhalten
aber auch dann zb flugabwehr panzer um
überhaupt gegen gegnerische luftangriffe
die möglichkeit zu haben diese
gepanzerten reserven ins gefecht zu
führen sonst werden dir schon vorher
ausgeschaltet durch luftschläge bevor
sie überhaupt ins gefecht dringen können
und das gilt sowohl für die offensive
als auch die defensive man braucht auch
panzer zum verteidigen dann schauen wir
auf das was die russen möglicherweise
als angriff verstehen könnten eine frage
von enrico ganz über youtube der fragt
wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
russland eine gegenoffensive auf die
besetzten gebiete als angriff auf
russland deklariert ist dann eine
russische generalmobilmachung denkbar
und als ergänzung dazu werfen wir ganz
kurz einen blick auf die stadt belgorod
denn am wochenende
hat das russische fernsehen bilder von
einem mutmaßlichen ukrainischen angriff
gezeigt auf die russische großstadt
belgorod bei dem vier menschen ums leben
gekommen sein sollen das wäre der
bislang folgenschwerste angriff auf
russisches gebiet ball fliegt in
belgorod entscheidung liegt in der nähe
von graz liegt etwa 30 kilometer hinter
der grenze zur ukraine hier sehen wir es
noch mal also das könnte herr dressel
bin gespannt wie sie das einschätzen
eine false flag aktion gewesen sein oder
ein tatsächlicher angriff und um auch
mal auf die frage des users
zurückzukommen eine möglichkeit um zu
sagen wir werden angegriffen wir machen
jetzt generalmobilmachung
also was den angriff bilden angeht würde
ich den präsidenten wenn die
generalmobilmachung es sehr
unwahrscheinlich
einschätzen falls die ukraine die kräfte
hätte zum beispiel grimm zurückerobern
dann würde die situation etwas anderes
aussagen weil die grünen ja schon also
erstmal mail en gros russisches
staatsgebiet und die ukraine will will
es zurückhaben und dann würde man mit
formellen mit gepanzerten verbänden
rüber stoßen eine artillerie schlag
über auf russisches territorium oder
einen raketenangriff das hat es ja schon
in der vergangenheit gegeben muss auch
sagen das sind
logistische infrastruktur die den
kriegen der ukraine dient ist laut
genfer konvention einer
landkriegsordnung ein legitimes
angriffsziel
bei diesem spezifischen angriff muss ich
auch sagen ich weiß wirklich nicht was
dahinter steht es gibt nur bilder aus
der nacht ist eine detonation gegeben
hat wie gesagt es gäbe in belgrad
genügend legitime ziele für einen
möglichen angriff etwa die eisenbahn
verladestationen die bahnhöfe die für
den russischen nachschub nachhaltig
dienen es gibt öllager dort die durch
die russische armee genutzt werden
allerdings dieser angriff war im
stadtzentrum
es gibt aber keine bilder von zum
beispiel trümmerteilen von
raketensystemen es gibt keine bilder die
den angriff hergang wirklich so zeigen
dass man rückschlüsse schließen könnte
was da passiert ist es gab in diesem
krieg schon einige auf russischer seite
inszenierte ford flex ich kann jetzt
natürlich auch nicht sagen ob es einer
war oder nicht ich kann weder das eine
noch das andere ausschließen details
kommen üblicherweise erst nach mehreren
wochen wirklich zum vorschein dann
müssen die unabhängig überprüft werden
müssen fotos auf ihre echtheit überprüft
werden da müssen dann gelände
gegebenheiten überprüft werden wo genau
welcher trümmerteile wirklich runter
gekommen ist oder ob das eine einen
rückschluss auf eine angriffs richtung
auf eine verwendung eines waffensystems
wirklich zulässt also das dauert alles
noch und das kann man bei diesem angriff
wirklich noch nicht seriös sagen weder
in die eine noch in die andere richtung
aber wie gesagt ein einzelner angriff es
gab dieses beispiel schon auf dem
russischen militär flughafen bei rostock
es gab bilder wurde die raffinerie auch
schon mal durch ukrainische drohnen
getroffen also dass das gibt es schon
solche vereinzelte angriffe auf punkt
ziele
lösen aber noch nicht die mobil machen
aus eine letzte frage an sie zur frage
was ist das ziel russlands teil ziele
wurden erreicht mit der eroberung dieser
gebiete jetzt frank die entscheidung
nicht frank ein user namens batzer fragt
über youtube was passiert wenn putin den
krieg nach der einnahme des don was für
beendet erklärt
ich glaube es nicht
das kommt sehr darauf an also wenn er
das für beendet erklärt unter welchen
umständen das ist und was dann sozusagen
seine formelle position ist also in
seiner gegenwärtigen rhetorik ist ja
immer noch das ziel die ukraine als
ganzes auszuschalten und die ukraine so
wie sie heute ist
von der karte zu fegen das problem ist
das kann er militärisch zumindest im
schnellen anlauf nicht mehr erreichen
jetzt ist die frage was passiert wenn
sich zum beispiel die russische
offensive erschöpft und muss dann
einfach zum beispiel die leute ausgehen
und man einen einseitigen
waffenstillstand haben will so etwas wie
das
2015 war wo damals hat sich auch die
ukraine erschöpft dann hat man das
minsker abkommen geschlossen und das war
dann ein sehr brüchiger waffenstillstand
der im grunde gegen den krieg nur ein
bisschen beruhigt hat und dann nach
einigen jahren setzt russland von vorne
an das wäre auch dann die gefahr eines
solchen abschlusses dass es eben kein
frieden wäre sondern nur an einen
waffenstillstand und das ist nichts
dauerhaftes wer sondern etwas nur
temporär ist das kann man aber im grunde
erst dann sagen wenn es soweit ist
zurzeit liegt ja kein weder ein angebot
noch eine gesprächsbereitschaft vor das
heißt die diskussionen wieder krieg
beendet werden kann wann er beendet
werden kann unter welchen bedingungen er
beendet werden kann die sind zurzeit
einfach noch spekulation da ist zurzeit
nichts greifbares da wo man sagen kann
das wäre eine chance das wäre nicht
chance